ou préjugés implicites.
Et ça se traduit par un manque ridiculement néfaste
de diversité dans nos entreprises
en particulier dans les secteurs influents.
N'est-ce pas, cher Cabinet Fédéral australien ?
(Applaudissements)
Laissez-moi éclaircir un point important.
Ne confondez pas préjugés inconscients et discrimination volontaire.
Je ne dis pas qu'en chacun de vous se cache un sexiste, un raciste,
ou un âgiste qui attend de pouvoir sortir.
Ce n'est pas ce que je dis.
Nous avons tous des préjugés.
Nous voyons le monde qui nous entoure à travers eux.
Je n'accuse personne.
Ce n'est pas un crime.
Nous devons seulement identifier nos préjugés,
en prendre conscience et les combattre.
Ils peuvent concerner la race
ou bien le sexe.
Et aussi la classe sociale, l'éducation ou le handicap d'une personne.
En fait, nous avons tous des préjugés sur ce qui est différent,
sur ce qui sort des normes sociales.
Le problème, c'est que si nous voulons vivre dans un monde
où les circonstances de notre naissance
n'influence pas notre avenir
et où l'égalité des chances est une évidence
alors chacun d'entre nous a un rôle à jouer
pour s'assurer qu'aucun préjugé inconscient ne dirigent nos vies.
Une célèbre expérience a été menée concernant les préjugés inconscients
portant sur le sexe dans les années 70-80.
Les orchestres à l'époque étaient constitués en majorité d'hommes
avec seulement 5% de femmes.
Apparemment, on pensait que les hommes jouaient différemment
probablement mieux... probablement.
Mais en 1952 l'Orchestre Symphonique de Boston
entama une expérience.
Ils firent des auditions à l'aveugle.
Au lieu de faire face au jury le candidat jouait derrière un écran.
Curieusement,
aucun changement n'a été immédiatement observé
jusqu'à ce qu'on demande aux candidats de retirer leurs chaussures
avant d'entrer dans la pièce.
Parce que le claquement des talons
contre le parquet
suffisait à trahir l'identité des femmes.
Ecoutez ça :
les résultats de l'audition ont montré
qu'une femme avait 50% de chances en plus
de passer avec succès le premier stade des éliminatoires.
Et qu'elle avait trois fois plus de chance d'être prise.
Qu'est-ce que ça montre ?
Malheureusement pour les hommes ils ne jouent pas différemment,
mais on avait l'impression que c'était le cas.
Et c'était ce préjugé qui déterminait leur réussite.
Nous venons donc d'identifier et de reconnaître l'existence
d'un préjugé.
Et nous faisons tous ça.
Je vais vous donner un exemple.
Un père et son fils ont un horrible accident de voiture.
Le père meurt sur le coup
et le fils, qui est gravement blessé, est emmené en urgence à l'hôpital.
Le médecin regarde l'enfant quand il arrive
et déclare qu'il ne peut pas opérer.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que l'enfant est son fils.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Mesdames et Messieurs,
le médecin est la mère de l'enfant.
Maintenant levez la main sans honte,
levez la main si vous pensiez au départ que le médecin était un homme ?
Voici la preuve que les préjugés inconscients existent
mais nous devons tous nous en rendre compte
et chercher des moyens de les dépasser
pour pouvoir trouver des solutions.
Et parmis les choses intéressantes
concernant les préjugés inconscients on trouve le sujet des quotas.
C'est quelque chose dont on parle souvent.
Et parmi les critiques il y a l'idée de mérite.
Ecoutez, je ne veux pas être choisie parce que je suis une femme.
Je veux être choisie parce que je le mérite,
et que je suis la plus qualifiée pour ce job.
C'est un sentiment assez répandu parmi les femmes ingénieurs
avec qui je travaille et que je connais.
Je sais de quoi je parle, j'en suis une.
Mais si cette idée de mérite est vraie,
pourquoi, comme le montre une expérience organisée par l'université de Yale en 2012
pour des C.V. identiques envoyés pour un poste de technicien de laboratoire,
pourquoi une Jennifer serait-elle jugée moins compétente,
aurait-elle moins de chance d'obtenir le poste,
et serait-elle moins bien payée qu'un John ?
Le préjugé inconscient est là,
et nous devons trouver un moyen de le dépasser.
Et vous savez, c'est intéressant,
il y a des recherches qui expliquent ça,
pourquoi on appelle ça le paradoxe du mérite.
Dans ces organisations, et c'est assez ironique,
dans ces organisations qui parlent du mérite comme de leur vertu phare
quant à leurs embauches
ils sont plus susceptibles d'embaucher des hommes et de les payer plus
parce qu'apparemment le mérite est une qualité masculine.
Attendez !
Vous pensez que vous me connaissez bien
que vous savez ce qui se passe.
Pouvez-vous m'imaginer piloter un truc comme ça ?
Vous pouvez imaginer que j'arrive et que je fais
« Hé les gars, voilà ce qui se passe. C'est comme ça qu'on fait. »
Je suis contente que vous le puissiez.
(Applaudissements)
Parce que mesdames et messieurs, c'est mon boulot.
Ce qui est bien avec ce boulot c'est que c'est assez amusant.
En fait, en Malaisie
inutile de parler d'une musulmane sur une plateforme.
Il y en a trop.
Mais c'est marrant.
Je me revois dire à un des gars
« Hé, mec, j'ai vraiment envie d'apprendre à surfer. »
Il a dit : « Yassmin je ne vois pas comment tu peux surfer
avec tout ce barda sur toi,
et je ne connais pas de plages réservées aux femmes. »
Et puis le gars a trouvé une idée brillante
Il m'a dit : « Tu diriges cette organisation,
Jeunesse Sans Frontière, non ?
Pourquoi tu ne crées pas une ligne de vêtements de plage pour musulmanes ?
Tu peux l'appeler « Jeunesse Sans Short de Bain. »
(Rires)
Et j'étais là : « Merci les gars. »
Et je me rappelle d'un autre gars qui me disait que je devrais
manger autant de yaourt que possible
parce que c'était toute la culture que j'allais trouver là-bas.
Et le problème c'est que c'était assez vrai,
parce qu'on manque cruellement de diversité dans nos employés,
surtout à des postes influents.
En 2010,
l'Université Nationale australienne a fait un test
en envoyant 4 000 candidatures identiques
à des postes en bas de l'échelle pour la plupart.
Pour obtenir le même nombre d'entretiens que quelqu'un avec un nom anglo-saxon
vous devez envoyer 68% de candidatures en plus si vous êtes Chinois.
Si vous êtes du Moyen-Orient ...Abdel-Magied...
vous devez en envoyer 64% de plus
et si vous êtes Italien vous avez de la chance
vous ne devez en envoyer que 12% supplémentaires.
Dans la Silicon Valley ce n'est pas tellement mieux.
Des résultats de diversité sont sortis sur Google
et il y a 61% de Blancs, 30% d'Asiatiques et quelques 9% de Noirs, d'Hispaniques
et de tous les autres. Et ce n'est pas bien mieux
dans le reste du secteur de la technologie, ils l'ont admis,
mais je ne suis pas sûre qu'ils fassent grand chose.
Le truc, c'est que ça n'évolue pas au sommet.
Une étude réalisée par Green Park,
un fournisseur de cadres supérieurs en Grande-Bretagne,
montre que plus de la moitié des 100 plus grandes entreprises
n'ont que des directeurs blancs dans leurs rangs,
exécutifs ou non.
Et deux sur trois n'ont pas de cadres
issus d'une minorité.
Et la plupart de ceux qui ont réussi à atteindre ce niveau
sont des directeurs non-exécutifs.
Ils n'ont donc pas beaucoup d'influence.
Je vous ai dit pas mal de trucs horribles.
Vous vous dites :
« Mon dieu, c'est affreux ! Qu'est-ce que je peux faire ? »
Heureusement,
nous avons vu qu'il y avait un problème.
Les opportunités manquent et c'est dû aux préjugés inconscients.
Mais vous vous dites peut-être:
« Je ne suis pas noir. Qu'est-ce que ça peut me faire ? »
Je vais vous le dire.
Comme je l'ai déjà dit,
nous vivons dans un monde où nous recherchons un idéal.
Et si nous voulons créer un monde
où nos origines n'ont pas d'importance
nous devons tous participer à la solution.
Et l'auteur de l'expérience sur les C.V. de laboratoire
a trouvé un début de solution.
Elle a dit que ce qui rassemblait les femmes qui ont réussi
l'unique chose qu'elles ont en commun
était qu'elles avaient de bons mentors.
Nous avons tous entendu parler de mentors
c'est chose courante.
Voici un nouveau défi pour vous.
Je vous défie tous et toutes de conseiller quelqu'un de différent.
Pensez-y.
Nous voulons tous conseiller quelqu'un qui nous semble familier,
qui nous ressemble,
avec qui on partage des choses.
Si je vois une musulmane mal se comporter
Je lui dis « Ça va ? On peut parler. »
Vous entrez dans une pièce où quelqu'un a été à l'école avec vous,
qui fait les mêmes sports,
il y a de fortes chances pour que vous vouliez aider cette personne.
Mais pour la personne dans la pièce qui n'a pas de point commun avec vous,
c'est très difficile de retrouver la même envie.
Trouver quelqu'un de différent à conseiller,
quelqu'un qui ne vient pas du même milieu que vous,
quel que soit ce milieu,
revient à ouvrir des portes aux gens qui ne pouvait même pas
atteindre la fichue entrée.
Parce que, Mesdames et Messieurs, le monde est injuste.
On ne naît pas tous avec les mêmes chances.
Je suis née dans l'une des plus pauvres villes du monde : Khartoum.
Je suis née noire, je suis une femme,
et je suis musulmane dans un monde où on se méfie de cette religion
pour des raisons que je ne contrôle pas.
Mais je reconnais aussi que je suis née avec des privilèges.
Mes parents sont géniaux,
j'ai reçu une bonne éducation,
et j'ai eu l'immense chance d'immigrer en Australie.
J'ai aussi eu la chance d'avoir des mentors géniaux
qui m'ont ouvert des portes dont j'ignorais jusqu'à l'existence.
Un mentor qui m'a dit
« Ton histoire est intéressante.
Écrivons quelque chose dessus pour que je puisse la partager. »
Un mentor qui m'a dit :
« Je sais que tu n'as vraiment rien à faire sur un derrick australien
mais viens quand même. »
Voilà où j'en suis, face à vous.
Et je ne suis pas la seule.
Il y a toutes sortes de gens dans ma communauté
que j'ai vus être aidés par des mentors.
Un jeune musulman à Sydney
qui a fini par se servir de l'aide de son mentor
pour commencer à faire du slam à Bankstown
et qui a aujourd'hui réussi.
Et il peut changer la vie de tellement d'autres jeunes.
Ou une femme à Brisbane,
une réfugiée afghane,
qui parlait à peine anglais en arrivant en Australie.
On lui a permis de devenir médecin
et elle a reçu le prix du Jeune Queenslander de l'année en 2008.
C'est un modèle.
Ce n'est vraiment pas facile.
C'est moi.
Mais je suis aussi la femme en tenue de travail orange,
et je suis aussi la femme en abaya du début.
Auriez-vous décidé de me conseiller si vous m'aviez vue
dans ces autres versions de moi-même ?
Parce que je suis la même personne.
Nous devons regarder au-delà de nos préjugés inconscients
trouver quelqu'un à conseiller qui est à l'opposé de notre univers,
car les changements profonds prennent du temps
et que je ne suis pas aussi patiente.
Si nous devons créer un changement,
si nous devons créer un monde,
où nous avons tous ce genre d'opportunités,
alors choisissez d'ouvrir la porte aux gens.
Parce que vous pensez peut-être que la diversité n'a rien à voir avec vous
mais nous appartenons tous au système.
Nous pouvons tous contribuer à la solution.
Si vous ne savez pas où trouver quelqu'un de différent,
allez là où vous n'allez jamais.
Si vous allez dans un lycée privé,
allez dans une école publique,
ou faites juste un saut dans votre centre local de soutien aux réfugiés.
Vous travaillez peut-être dans un bureau.
Invitez à sortir ce jeune diplômé qui n'a pas l'air à sa place...
exactement comme moi...
et ouvrez-lui des portes
pas juste pour la forme, nous ne sommes pas des victimes,
mais montrez-leur des opportunités,
parce qu'ouvrir votre monde
vous fera comprendre que vous avez accès à des portes
dont ils ignoraient l'existence même,
et dont vous ignoriez qu'ils n'y avaient pas accès.
Mesdames et Messieurs,
le manque d'opportunités est un problème pour notre communauté
surtout dû à des préjugés inconscients.
Mais chacun d'entre vous a le potentiel de changer ça.
Je sais que je vous ai lancé beaucoup de défis aujourd'hui
mais si vous pouviez prendre celui-ci et y pensez un peu différemment,
parce que la diversité est magique.
Et je vous encourage à regarder au-delà de vous premières impressions
parce que je vous parie
qu'elles sont probablement fausses.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)